We have a voicemail number which I invite
you to call absolutely anytime of day.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a voicemail with a question
about maybe how we might interpret the current
state of a political affairs.
Take a look.
Yeah, hey, they were gonna mention something
when nobody's mentioned yet.
I believe the David.
Donald Trump presence.
The revenge for electing a black man as President
Barack Obama.
Tell you what.
This is why the Republicans are letting them
go.
I've never heard this mention.
And I believe this is true.
Listen, I have heard it mentioned this idea
that the reason Trump got elected is a racist
response to Barack Obama.
Now, what's really I mean, address that in
a second.
There is a slice of the left that likes to
say Barack Obama's centrism and failing the
middle class is what got Trump elected.
There's people on the left who like to say
that in order to then say as a result, the
last thing we need is Joe Biden, because it'll
just lead to another Donald Trump.
I think that this is actually an interesting
idea that the caller presents, which is that
there was such racist rage about Barack Obama
that there are people who would not maybe
normally have voted for Donald Trump, but
did in order to punish the Democratic Party
for electing a black man.
I think it exists.
I don't know that it's the predominant factor.
I do think that there are a lot of race related
elements, including the fear of losing status
as some middle class white voters may may
have experienced.
I don't think that straight up racism is really
responsible for Donald Trump in the way.
Racist backlash.
I guess we were caught in the way this caller
is referring to.
But we are a country of three hundred and
thirty one million people.
There's a little bit of everything.
Right.
James Combs press conference about Hillary
probably swung some votes.
Racism in response to Barack Obama probably
swung some votes.
Russian social media campaigns swung some
votes.
You can't say that it's one thing, but it's
certainly an interesting component.
We have a great bonus show planned for you
today.
Burger King is wanting to address climate
change by changing the diets of cows where
it gets its meat.
What?
We'll talk about that.
We will also talk about a new study which
shows that minimum wage in any U.S. state
does not allow you to afford rent.
OK.
Horrifying numbers.
And I'm actually going to do it.
I'm going to talk a little bit about que que
anon que a non cannon, as I like to call it.
Sometimes on today's bonus show, get instant
access to the bonus show at Join Patman dot
com.
Today's bonus show is a good one.
Otherwise, I'll see you tomorrow.